um what do you guys what do y'all want  if you guys wanted to get married what  would you look for in a wife  I'm gonna get hate for this book  submissiveness oh that's okay oh okay  that's fine  for me um look I'm I'm a Muslim I'm I I  may not be religious but I try to be  submission isn't the word that I tend to  use you're like if a woman is submissive  to God then she will do her Duty as a  wife yeah what I require from a wife is  fun if there's one word is  cooperativeness what does that mean that  you have a wife a partner that is gonna  ride or die with you towards the same  goal towards the same end yeah that is  the fundamental quality that I require  from a woman Beauty will fade facts  Beauty will fade